bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vue avec
une actualité encore largement dominée
par la disparition de johnny hallyday et
par les préparatifs de l'hommage
populaire qui lui sera rendu samedi à
paris on s'interrogera ensemble sur une
question qui peut paraître protée calais
ronchon même en fait trop pour la mort
de johnny ou au contraire ce dernier
voyage de l'idole permet-il aux français
de se rassembler nous parlerons aussi de
jérusalem jérusalem reconnu capitale
d'israël par les états unis
la décision de donald trump provoque un
tollé le hamas appelle au soulèvement
des palestiniens vous allez nous donner
votre point de vue sur cette diplomatie
du coup de poker
nous évoquons également cette étude qui
montre que les français sont inquiets
pour leur sécurité leur sécurité au
quotidien plus inquiet que jamais
justifié ou pas vous nous direz ce que
vous en pensez
et enfin nous anticipons un peu sur
l'élection ce week-end à la tête des
républicains
alain juppé qui votera pour la outsiders
mail de calan nicolas sarkozy qui donne
un coup de pouce de main à laurent
wauquiez le grand favori avec quelle
image la droite sortira-t-elle de ce
scrutin on verra tout cela alors
n'hésitez pas vous qui nous suivait
prononcez vous sur ces différents thèmes
vous le faites via twitter hashtag
figaro live #primaires pour en parler
autour de cette table françois reynaert
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous avez un ami et à l'ops l'aube ce
qui naturellement consacre un numéro
spécial à johnny comme on le voit
peut-être l'écran c'est le rockeur
l'idole des jeunes que vous avez choisi
de retenir en une
vous êtes également écrivain est votre
dernier ouvrage céiste orama quand
l'histoire explique l'actualité c'est
paru chez tallandier
alors johnny est ce que c'est l'histoire
de france aussi on va on va en parler
dans un instant bonjour emmanuel rivière
vous êtes directeur de l'institut kantar
public et vous enseigner la
communication politique la politique
johnny la récupération peut-être ou pas
on va voir tout cela
bonjour olivier duhamel à au jour merci
d'être assidus à point de vue vous êtes
juriste vous présidez la fondation
nationale des sciences politiques et
vous êtes journaliste aussi comme
présenter l'émission médiapolis le
samedi matin sur europe 1 votre dernier
livre s'intitule macro et en même temps
il a été créé avec laurent bigot et
alice beaudry est paru chez plon
et bonjour alexis brézet vous dirigé les
rédactions du figaro qui n'ont pas chômé
cd
jour le figaro le figaro magazine figaro
live les hors séries
elles ont essayé de donner le meilleur
pour parler de johnny et de jean
d'ormesson
alors cet hommage à johnny un cortège
funéraire qui descendra les champs
elysées jusqu'à la concorde
un cortège qui sera accompagné par les
musiciens de johnny hallyday puis une
cérémonie religieuse qui aura lieu à la
madeleine et où emmanuel macron fera une
brève intervention indique-t-on à
l'elysée
c'est donc ainsi que la france se
retrouvera samedi autour du chanteur s
des obsèques à la hauteur de
l'attachement des français à la star est
ce au contraire un show démesuré
vous avez été nombreux à répondre ce
pour la question du jour du figaro et à
plus de 62%
vous dites oui oui c'est un hommage qui
est sans doute enfin que vous approuvez
en revanche plus d'un tiers donc estime
que c'est un peu trop
finalement on va faire un tour de table
cet hommage où vous êtes pour vous êtes
content dans la forme qu'on a qu'on a
défini olivier duhamel
ça vous paraît automne mais on
commençait pas moi écoutez d'abord
l'astuce c'est d'avoir choisi le
qualificatif populaire parce qu'on nous
annonçait un hommage national il fait
une demande pour la maj de sa valeur la
nationale quand même sort et et ça a été
beaucoup c'est pas tout à fait victor
hugo johnny beau mais cette formule là
et je pense fait un compromis qui peut
satisfaire tous les fans ou ceux qui
aiment beaucoup johnny ou ceux qui
aiment bien johnny est pas trop effrayer
les ronchons la dimension populaire
françois rennard c'est celle que vous
remercie moi je me sens je me sens pas
du tout ronchon je comprends
parfaitement qu'il y ait des fans qui
aiment johnny hallyday mais ça me paraît
surréaliste qui est là que qu'on dise la
france est représentée par daniel idées
moi je suis français enfin je croyais
jusqu'à hier être français et je me
reconnais en rien en généralité et pour
moi ça reste quand même
enfin je sais pas les deux les choses
qui me viennent à l'esprit c'est un
chanteur qui a une voix magnifique ce
sera qui avait une voix magnifique ça
c'est sûr et encore une fois je respecte
parfaitement les gens qui aiment
génialité mais on a le droit de ne pas
aimer géniale idée d'accord mais alors
on n'est pas en corée du nord encore là
il l'a et justement précisément olivier
il ya un petit côté corée du nord quand
même là le l'unanimisme absolu sur
johnny hallyday ça me paraît un petit
peu too much comme dirait johnny reid et
il faut on peut se souvenir aussi que
c'est un johnny hallyday c'est aussi
l'amérique
l'américanisation de la france c'est
aussi l'exil fiscal c'est aussi bon
voilà c'est pas des choses très
positives
j'étais plus rassuré plus français pour
l'hommage national à simone veil si vous
laissez ça me je me sentais plus dans
mon élément
une communion des français un peu
surjouée alexis alors il ya de choisir
d'abord le cadre juridique en fait dans
la tradition républicaine il ya deux
types de l'hommage national qui sera que
de qui sera par exemple autour de jean
d'ormesson il y aura un hommage national
l'hommage national c'est le président
république qui prend la parole dans un
lieu symbolique en l'occurrence la la
cour de la cour des invalides
après il ya une autre formule s'appelle
les funérailles nationales
il a les crocs victor hugo mais qu'ils
ont fournies n'ont pas de définition
juridique le seul point juridique c'est
que c'est l'état qui paie les finales il
ya que ça alors pour la question c'est
que là dessus
macron se dit effectivement peut-être
que national le mou fait trop donc on va
inventer cette nouvelle catégorie
le ride qui est quelque chose de
populaire qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
davantage d'existence juridique
c'est donc moi je suis plutôt pour
d'abord je pense que sur la personne
d'un pompier ne veut pas deuxième manche
moi je pense que johnny hallyday je dis
pas qu'ils représentent la france qui
représentent les français ne s'est pas
une incarnation ni un modèle idéal
je pense que dans ce qu'il est il
ressemble c'est un miroir qui rôdent
dans laquelle la france reconnaît
précisément pour ce que vous dites pour
ces contrôles exigeants fiscal oui bah
oui les français aiment trop défisc la
vérité nation serbe est aussi fixé mais
ça ne veut pas dire que c'est bien je
suis pas je dis pas que c'est un modèle
républicain jeudi que ce parcours de ce
type cabossé qui se relève qui se casse
la figure qui a tout était qui était
hippie qui a été au coeur qui a été
droguée et est père de famille et puis
non ses cheveux longs illégal oui il a
été ce vol ont ils des courtes contre
des fonds d aide bien sûr plus intérieur
du pee wee saveurs de répit avec un
disque dont la guitare s était jimmy
page et il
il a tout fait ça et il est illégal et
grégory est donc dans tous ses ce miroir
il y à quelque chose ses 50 ans de 60
ans d'histoire de la france je vous ai
tous lus par emmanuel rivière un
achalandage
c'est très manuelle rivière de saint
jean soit on sait au moins que alexis
sur johnny hallyday et ce matin je pense
que j'étais un peu ronchon en fait et
comme on en fait non pas sur mon point
de vue mais pour
éventuellement comprendre celui des
français j'ai essayé d'analyser ça je
pense qu'un décalage entre le phénomène
que représente johnny qui était capable
de remplir des stades de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes
donc un engouement très fort chez un
nombre très élevé de personnes qui
justifient pour moi parfaitement qu'on
donne à ses funérailles
la mesure de ce besoin que ses très
nombreux fans peuvent éprouver de
partager quelque chose à ce moment là
effectivement il y en a au référé à des
enquêtes je suis reporter à barrow med
mais estimé confrère de l'ifop sur les
personnalités préférées des français ou
johnny hallyday rarement apparu dans le
top 50 est assez mal classés je pense
qu'effectivement il n'est pas du tout si
consensuel que cela représente sans
doute une époque et je pense qu'il ya
aussi une dimension j'ai donné l'idée
très particulière c'est que tout le
monde connaît je puis dire c'est qu'ils
en parlent
on connaît ces femmes etc mais voilà si
on cherche une personnalité consensuelle
la sphère du baromètre ifop ses larges
at elle même mais bien sûr c'est pas de
toi d'honneur de son moral c'est pas du
tout 10.10 positif diana l'idée oui
c'était aussi donc avec ses excès resort
en quoi en quoi il faut le célébrer en
quoi ça donne des valeurs qu'ils ont dit
la france je dis pas que des valeurs
cuba alors qu'ils pensaient alors que le
besoin de rassemblement est ce que c'est
un sujet oui mais le besoin de
rassemblement dans une nation il doit se
faire sur les valeurs partagées
on parlait des funérailles nationales de
victor hugo victor hugo c'était
l'incarnation de la république naissante
à cause de sa lutte contre l' empire et
c'est simone veil s'est fait à
l'incarnation mal tourné oui enfin bon
qui était applicable
oui parce que parce que justement il y
avait encore une opposition et encore
n'est pas la france qui refusait sa mémé
là il n'ya même pas d'opposition de rien
c'est juste
il ya des fans qui aiment bien john
alité formidable enfin pas un formidable
je veux dire ils achèteront ces disques
et c'est vrai c'est très bien et qu'ils
soient très triste aujourd'hui je le
comprends et je le respecte parfaitement
il n'y a aucune raison de se moquer tard
mais en quoi ça regarde la nation
française parce que plus de personnes
quasiment incarne des valeurs partagées
geste est sage et si j'étais que simon
est vivant non mais bien si on mettait
deux vivent pas quelle rubrique sa
prétendue mais je pense que ce qui est
révélateur là dedans aussi
ce que ça révèle ces noms pas forcément
de des français mais peut-être plus
encore du président de la république de
maquereaux c'est à dire de son obsession
de son désir constant de trouver de
fabriquer des héros de son histoire sa
les décliner le roman des 15 dernières
années de l'histoire de france c'est que
les quatre murs d'une france privée de
héros disséqua héros national et il
estime par ailleurs là pour le coup de
13 n'exagérait c'est pas du tout héros
national
ils étaient quelque chose qui a suscité
un écho notamment dans la france
populaire
simone veil était très populaire mais il
y avait pas d elle faisait pas créé des
rassemblements avec des ouvriers des
employés des gens modestes et voir
simone veil ça c'est pas vrai johnny
hallyday l'avait quand même ce quelque
chose d'assez particulier et si c'est
presque un symbole va devoir le vendredi
les obsèques de jean d'ormesson qui
était une france traditionnel hristo
cratique bonjour est cultivé littéraire
parisienne etc
et le lendemain johnny une france
vraiment populaire face il fallait aller
dans les concerts de johnny et basse
je trouve ça petit lit cela représente
quelque chose puisse en rien un héros
national mais parce que je n'ai les
caractéristiques star qui s'est invité
des gens ils sont à l'honneur est sauf
et effectivement de cette dimension là
avec intel familiarité avec sa vie je
pense que beaucoup de français
finalement perdu quelqu'un qu'il
connaissait mais je pense que rafa va y
avoir un décalage entre ces français qui
sont nombreux à être très triste
et puis tous ceux qui effectivement bon
voilà qu'il n'aimait pas plus que ça
johnny pouvons penser qu'on en fait trop
sera pas très grave d'ailleurs la france
s'en remettra il y aura la fois beaucoup
de gens qui vont l'accompagner sur les
gens lisent elysées et beaucoup de gens
qui vont trouver qu'on en fait un peu
trop et c'est là où se nichent peut-être
le danger pourrait tellement les
personnalités politiques qui donneront
le sentiment de vouloir surfer à
conférer un prélat comprends l'émotion
des fans même si on ne partage pas on
comprend moins et on est moins tolérants
vers ce qu'elle surfait sur les émotions
je vous propose d'écouter l'historien
yves santamaria il était ce matin sur
rtl lui sont proposés t on va l'écouter
mais il dit il a écrit d'ailleurs
devenir le johnny sociologie d'un
rockeur est découverte et idy les
disques de johnny pourront aider à
comprendre le 20e siècle on l'écouté du
futur recours recourir à diony pour
comprendre le xxème siècle français il
ne restait que le les disques de johnny
très certainement un historien du futur
auraient bien davantage que les des
collègues et l'ennemi gens ont sous la
main pour comprendre le chèque de 2
péricles avant qu'on reprenne ce débat
je vous donne quelques réactions alors
brigitte se démener nous dit attention
on en fait trop tomber dans l'outrance
nicole sap qui dit qu'à affaires macron
dans cet hommage vous en parler c'est
pour remonter dans les sondages
demande-t-elle en revanche n'a dit elle
ou il le mérite je regrette seulement de
ne pouvoir y être d'autres nous disent
d'ormesson a été lâchement oublié par
john y est c'est trop enfin vous bon il
ya vraiment toutes sortes de réactions
assez assez partagés finalement alexis
sur le côté macron non mais c'est sûr il
sans doute je pense qu'il a cette vision
profondément enfin au fond du délit
d'aidé évoqué des héros et des héros
positif et donc il va prendre celui-là
qui à mon sens n'est pas un héros
l'inégalité traitement avec jean
d'ormesson il est peut-être vrai du
produit médiatique pas du point de vue
institutionnel demain emmanuel macron
prononcera un discours dans la cour
d'honneur des invalides devant la
dépouille de jean d'ormesson
les honneurs militaires lui seront
rendus et c'est donc de ce point de vue
si on voulait faire une comparaison un
pub sur mes jean d'ormesson est mieux
traité entre guillemets deux points de
vue républicain que que johnny hallyday
après l'aller millions de personnes et
seront sur le leader sahin valley de la
proposition implicite d'emmanuel rivière
de déterminer la hiérarchie des hommages
par la place dans les sondages moroses
et non vous avez cités je vous taquine
un peu et qui est toujours très
dangereux d'ailleurs vous n'aimez pas
trop taquiner je sais mais vous avez dit
que vous avez pris comme référence
votre point de vue sur l'hommage à
johnny ce qu'il était excessif quand
ceux ci que je n'y ai mal placé ou
n'apparaît pas dans les sondages des
personnalités du jdd qui donc en écho à
celle qui est mon propos parce que j'ai
professeur geim pas être j'aurais pu
attaquer j'espère pouvoir donner la
bonne réponse est pas si je pense que
les français n'aimaient pas unanimement
johnny c'est tout ce que je voulais dire
avec avec ce jeu là référence à ce
sondage par rapport à d'autres chanteurs
qui sont plus consensuels même temps il
ya une puissance de la nouvelle
puissance évocatoire johnny hallyday qui
sans doute unique mais qui ne concerne
pas tout le monde est il d'ailleurs ce
qui te manque peut-être c'est que c'est
la nouveauté de ce besoin
alors est-ce que ce besoin d'être
particulièrement nettement qui forgez
macron que en vérité dans l'opinion
c'est possible mais je veux dire à ma
connaissance ni brassens barbara dans
quoi que ce soit aux yeux des hommages
populaire alors que c'était je demande
urgente est celle des coeurs fédéral
parce qu'elle a été assistante parce que
les vétérinaires sont là il y avait
quelque chose d'héroïque année
mais mais pas pardon juste mais il ya eu
le même doublé si je puis dire pour
parler de mort c'est un peu des cas mais
avec cocteau et piaf là tout le monde
par exemple et à ce moment là il ya eu
une vague d'émotion populaire qui était
assez comparable en fait le plan
politique je suis la joute parce que
c'est une info figaro qu'on vient de
m'annoncer que françois hollande a dit
qu'il trouvait cet hommage approprié
qu'il s'y rendrait ainsi que hannigan
anne hidalgo et par ailleurs comme on le
sait depuis quelques heures il y aura
des images de johnny projeté sur la tour
eiffel et tous les matchs de foot
commenceront pas avant la pression on
s'interrogeait je n'ai pas la réponse
emmanuel macron parlant en tant que
président d'un public dans l'église de
la madeleine c'est ce que en tout cas
l'intervention à la madeleine
je sais pas si c'est une se demande
effectivement c'est passé un précédent
dans l'histoire de france d'un président
de la république parlant d'une église
parlant dans une église il n'y a pas de
précédent et 2
vous allez voir les commentaires de fans
et après demain côté valley qui va s'en
prend plein la figure
je vous propose d'alors parmi les
personnalités aimé des français je sais
pas son niveau de classement il ya
michel drucker michel drucker qui hier
ne cachait pas son émotion
c'était à la fin de l'émission spéciale
de france 2 au moment du générique dans
ma carrière c'est l'ong déjà j'ai vu
partir beaucoup de copains
lui c'était spécial je vous demande
pardon tu aurais pu vivre encore un peu
de vie oui je sais que nous ne reverrons
un jour ou l'autre ça lui manque
parmi ce qu'on disait de laver mon cher
qui envoie son émotion
il y avait ce côté aussi johnny
effectivement un peu caméléon qui a su
traverser les époques et tout ça ça fait
partie aussi de sa personnalité
merouane mehadji merci nous nous
rejoindre qu'est-ce que là-dessus
effectivement vous avez regardez un peu
ce qu'ils disent et sur les réseaux
sociaux
c'est assez partagés ou c'est sur le
côté faut-il rendre un hommage populaire
et jusqu'à quel point on en fait trop
alors johnny depuis hier c'est l'un des
sujets les plus commentés en france sur
les réseaux sociaux mais aussi sur notre
site lefigaro.fr
alors aujourd'hui c'est un peu éclipsé
avec l'actuel internationale et
notamment donald trump et la
reconnaissance de jérusalem comme
capitale d'israël
mais aujourd'hui les twitts et plus des
messages autour des funérailles plus que
des messages triste comme on pouvait en
avoir hier depuis sa mort on compte plus
de 1 million 500 mille tweets postés
donc c'est l'un des plus gros sujet de
l'année et sur notre site et notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux comme facebook
c'est l'un des sujets les plus commentés
depuis depuis juillet notamment on a eu
plus de 23000 500 ménages a posté hier
et alors pour les messages qui parle de
des funérailles on a énormément de
personnes qui nous disent depuis
aujourd'hui j'ai remarqué ça depuis ce
matin des personnes qui nous dit
justement comme on le dit depuis tout à
l'heure que c'est un peu exagéré
j'en ai sélectionné 5 on a notamment un
manuel montano qui nous dit je suis de
la génération johnny j'ai vibré avec ses
chansons mais pourquoi lui et pas les
autres
j'avais aussi une admiration profonde
pour jean rochefort je trouve que macron
fait du populisme
en fait il dessert la mort de johnny on
à sybille dans la même veine qui nous
dit un hommage à ce grand artiste qui a
porté une génération wii de cette
envergure qui le fait rejoindre deux
rares autres tels que victor hugo non
trop en de trop de démesure qui
ternissent la mémoire et les hommages
rendus la veille à jean d'ormesson
vraiment exagéré quand à la place quant
à la classe politique elle n'a pas sa
place à la madeleine respectons johnny
sa famille ses enfants et mettons les
choses à leur juste place
désolé et pourtant je reconnais à johnny
ce qu'on lui doit d'émotion et de
moments heureux
c'est vraiment ça qu'on a parmi les
commentaires même les personnes qui le
soutiennent trouve que
c'est trop on a notamment écrit qui nous
dit c'est une personnalité emblématique
de la scène musicale française donc où
il n'est pas anormal qu'un hommage
solennel sonel solennel lui sera rendu
maintenant ce n'est pas non plus la
personne la plus importante dans
l'histoire de france donc que cela se
fasse et qu'on passe à autre chose
et enfin ni daube alsace qui nous dit
que les choses soient claires je suis un
grand admirateur de johnny hallyday
depuis un demi siècle je regrette
énormément sa disparition bien que
sachant au fondement que c'est notre
sort commun alors un hommage des
hommages partout des rues des timbres à
son effigie
oui mais le panthéon là c'est non oui
puisqu'en fait il ya énormément
d'internautes qui parce que il ya encore
le panthéon savoir à combien de
personnes sur les champs elysées
beaucoup s'y intéressant dans tous ces
messages en fait c'est que je crois
qu'une grande partie sont animés par
leur détestation des politiques et que
donc quelles que soient leur ferveur
pour donner suite il soupçonne alors
réussi même à croire il ya un sim accord
n'a rien fait c'est scandaleux ce qui
fait un truc c'est ce qu'on a vécu dans
la rue c'est vrai c'est systématiquement
sa façon c'est le bleu le cousin
punching ball sur l apprenez à aimer ça
appartement où la famille accepte un
hommage de ce type et à la madeleine
c'est la même chose qu'eux même pas jean
françois hollande y aille parce que ce
serait je peux et ne peux pas failli et
la famille de notre ère la famille
accepte mais la famille elle veut johnny
lui-même avait dit que je voulais pas je
veux pas de funérailles
c'est à dire on fait comme on dit john
lennon on s'interrogeait sur pourquoi le
mot populaire été choisie on se dit
c'est parce que macron là si ça se
trouve je n'ai pas l'explication mais il
n'est pas impossible que ce soit parce
que johnny lui-même ayant dit je ne veux
pas de funérailles nationales
la vie de la famille alors on va pas
faire final on va faire un hommage
populaire
voilà je pense que faire si ce n'est la
seule explication
il avait dit façon pas non plus très
solennelle même si je trouve pas
terrible idée de funérailles nationales
je ne suis pas une star absolue je suis
un simple et déjà annoncé qu'elle
s'empresse et pauline de france et
c'était effectivement inférieur appel
mais rui dans les faits ce sera
effectivement un moment populaire où des
gens qui est partagé le même sentiment à
l'égard de jonnhy auront envie de
partager le même sentiment et besoin pas
forcément envie d'entendre des figures
extérieure à ce sentiment là donnez là
autant voir des gens qui l'ont connu ses
amis des vedettes du show-biz dire ça
permet de partager mais dans le moment
lui-même je pense que les gens auront
envie de se retrouver entre fans et pas
sous la houlette d'une autorité
quelconque alors sans forcément aller
jusque sur les champs elysées samedi de
lecture indispensable celle de du figaro
magazine hors série sur johnny une
légende française et le hors série du
figaro sur jean d'ormesson l'esprit
français avec une sélection de cemex
nous mettons dans ce témoignage c'est ce
qu'il est allé aux caméras regard décidé
médiapart alors on va passer à jérusalem
à quoi joue le président américain en
reconnaissant jérusalem comme capitale
d'israël
il joue avec le feu si l'on en croit la
désapprobation de la communauté
internationale et il risque de
déclencher une nouvelle intifada
en tout cas de quoi déstabiliser encore
un peu plus le moyen orient ou alors au
contraire donald trump un agenda caché
est ce une stratégie pour relancer le
processus de paix qui est bien en panne
on va en débattre
mais je vous propose d'abord d'écouter
manuel macron il était encore hier à
élever et il commentait cette décision
du président américain
c'est une décision regrettable que la
france n'approuve pas et qui contrevient
au droit international et aux
résolutions du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu et je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez toujours voter vous prononcer sur
ce point via twitter hashtag figaro live
acheté près de lui alors est ce que
finalement donald trump a une stratégie
ou pas françois reynaert
en tout cas je pense qu'il a une
stratégie intérieur malheureusement et
c'est ça le drame comme souvent avec la
politique étrangère américaine sait
qu'il a un agenda à terre intérieur
qu'il est là hein
il est coincé par le l'anc et russe donc
il faut qu'il trouve une échappatoire il
faut qu'ils trouvent quelque chose il y
avait cette chose que l'acquis et qui
arrivait il devait signer avant les six
mois où tu sais c'est là quelque part
oui tout à fait mais en tout cas ça lui
permet d'échapper à sa et deuxièmement
il fait plaisir à la partie des
chrétiens les plus conservateurs jeudi
les chrétiens sciemment parce que ça lui
il ya tout ce mouvement aux états unis
d'aider des sionistes chrétiens
d'équipage qui pensent que voilà qui
pensent qu'il faut absolument que
jérusalem soit une capitale et que les
juifs soient tous ceux en israël donc
ils sont ils défendent absolument la la
capitale des gaules et voilà mais cette
chose là pour des raisons de politique
interne abouti de fait à une catastrophe
une catastrophe c'est à dire s'est-il il
méprise les millions de gens pour qui
les queues plein de juifs se
reconnaissent dans jérusalem c'est tout
à fait respectable et toute louable tout
à fait normal et c'est beaucoup de
musulmans se reconnaissent aussi dans
jérusalem et ceux là aussi ont le droit
d'être écoutés c'est ce qui est
insupportable c'est l'idée jeu j'appuie
les uns et je méprise les autres mais
après tout les vidéos
on se dit c'est vrai ça patine depuis
des décennies est-ce qu'il lance pas un
grand copain fourmilière et puis ils
auraient raison d'abord dans le
hors-série que vous avez fait circuler
j'ai ouvert par hasard et ce tomb ya 40
ans paix aux hommes de bonne volonté par
jean d'ormesson et ça commence par un
cil invraisemblable inconcevable
impossible c'est produit le chef d'un
état en guerre est allé chez l'ennemi
lui proposer la paix est l'ennemi l'a
reçu dans une émotion indescriptible
c'était sa date à la knesset s'est s
adapte à tel-aviv
oui et moi je crois qu'il ya une
dimension absolument personnelle dans
l'acte de chang comme ce monsieur chiche
si vous me cherchez pas s'ils vont
provoquer bachy vous dites ne va pas
faire ça je vous emmerde et je le fais
et donc à chaque fois qu'un journal le
pointe à chaque fois que
l'administration explique ce n'est pas
comme ça qu'il faut faire et bien il
fait le contraire
je ne vois pas que ça puisse être un
facteur ne pas être franchement je vois
je pense que ça ça rend les états unis
encore plus marqués exclusivement du
côté d'israël donc ça va les empêcher de
jouer quelques rôle de médiation que ce
soit si tenté qu'il vous puisse encore
en jouer et donc c'est plus une
opération d'auto satisfaction
personnelle et de respect de
l'engagement de campagne mais tous ses
prédécesseurs avaient pris l'engagement
de campagne il en veut pas respecter
donc à des prêts et prévaloir les
impératifs diplomatiques la dynamite
encore un peu plus le processus de paix
moussa le relance soit pas vraiment quoi
ça le relance parce que premier
initiative
diplomatiques fin quand tout ça peut
arriver de dire on va renverser la table
mais ça veut dire qu'on a un plan
derrière qu'on a préparé des alliés des
appuis et qu'on se dit je fais bouger
les choses mais je sais que je vais
construire derrière là apparemment il
n'ya pas une seule voie dans le monde à
part à netanyahou ou encore bon qui ne
peut pas dire autre chose mais il n'y a
pas une seule voie dans le monde du pape
jusqu'au dernier chef d'état pour dire
que c'est une bonne idée donc
reconstruire à partir de ça ça me paraît
compliqué je crois et c'est
complémentaire de ce que de ce que dit
olivier c'est que trump se dit qu'il a
sur la scène diplomatique une liberté
qui n'a pas sur les affaires intérieures
on se rend compte que ce soit aux
affaires intérieures c'est très
difficile il est très bien contraire il
a un gros grain sénat alors sa réforme
fiscale va peut-être arriver mais c'est
quand même très compliqué en revanche
les a faites et mélodique finalement
s'il veut plus et donc ils fiche en
l'air les accords il d'afficher en clair
l'accord et lima l'accord de
libre-échange et et d'autres encore le
nucléaire iranien à chaque fois qu'il ya
un accord international qui peut même
fiche en l'air parce que ça il sait ça
dépend de lui et il peut le faire ce
qu'il ya derrière ça me le fait
maintenant reconstruire à partir de ça
ça me paraît très compliqué
la réaction de macron qu'on a montré
tout à l'heure est intéressante macron
dit la peur de rien ils cognent etc
il est prudent macron quand il s'agit
des états unis il fait attention c'est
une situation regrettable il a commencé
par dire c'est un regret ensuite il a
dit que c'est une décision qui le
désapprouvait qu'il désapprouvait il n'a
pas toujours que joe cole haan je sais
pas un reproche aux normes alexis en
termes diplomatiques
quand on quand on dit des relations
cordiales je veux dire qu'on est joe
borg faire la guerre alors quand on est
regrettable non c'est oui c'est je vous
dirais c'est intéressant c'est qu'il se
dit je pense que ce rôle de
reconstruction de d'intermédiaire il
sait très bien mais ça veut dire qu'il
faudra qu'il parle aussi avec les
américains ensuite et donc il ne dit pas
je condamne c'est intolérable et s'est
dit je désapprouve et moi j'en reste à
ce que dit la charte des nations unies
des accords d'oslo
de deux états avec pour capitale alors
nos internautes qui votent afin qu'ils
se prononcent en tout cas parce que sur
la question savoir si c'est un coup de
poker de trump sont assez partagés à 50
2% il estime que oui emmanuel rivière
je pense que les avis convergent autour
de ce plateau c'est que dans tous les
sens du terme jouer avec le feu
effectivement de trappes est en train de
jouer avec le feu ce câble ayant ce que
souligne alexis c'est que cette attitude
qui consiste à se déporter pour un
président américain sur les affaires
étrangères par manque de marge de
manoeuvre sur la scène intérieure se
produit extraordinaire mentaux dans le
premier mandat du président américain à
moins d'un an après son entrée en
fonction et il joue effectivement
vraiment avec le feu puisque dans la
question des rapports des états unis
avec israël il ya un certain nombre de
manières de donner satisfaction à des
attentes de l'état d'israël je pense que
d'ailleurs la remise en cause de
l'accord avec l'iran d'inquiétude mais
il serait jérusalem pardon ça prend
immédiatement une connotation religieuse
ce qui est effectivement le summum de la
pauvreté par rapport à jallais dire
l'équilibré précaire non le déséquilibre
établi de tous les dangers de la région
si je peux ajouter un mot qu'on n'a pas
parlé il ya un nom qui est pas qu on n'a
pas dit cmbs ou ryad l'arabie saoudite
iran parce que là je pense que
paradoxalement les plus embêtés dans
l'histoire c'est peut-être la droite
israélienne qui est au pouvoir la droite
de netanyahu parce que eux ils avaient
un grand fantasme dans la dette un grand
espoir c'est l'arabie saoudite puisque
mb s le nouveau chef de l'arabie
saoudite là il est complètement dingue
il veut que l'ennemi absolu c'est l'iran
il était prêt à tout y compris à faire
une alliance avec israël
et là je vois pas enfin je connais mal
l'arabie saoudite de l'intérieur mais je
ne vois pas que le peuple saoudien
accepte ce quelque chose c'est bien sûr
c'est trop trop fort jerusalem sait on
peut pas céder là dessus on peut faire
des échanges de territoires et cetera
pas jérusalem donc là je pense que c'est
une grosse connerie de trump qui doit
que dans soit se mordent les doigts
gelés les israéliens alors vous évoquez
une décision électorale ou
électoralistes de trump on va écouter
christophe castaner il en parlait ce
matin sur europe 1 christophe castaner
qui est donc le délégué général dans
marche et le secrétaire d'état chargé
des relations avec le parlement
je crois que la diplomatie des coups de
menton ne fait pas la meilleure du
mais si effectivement il peut générer
des tensions par cette décision
électoral qui est pas forcément une
décision diplomatique
la position de la france est celle de l'
équilibre c'est celle de la
reconnaissance de deux états qui doivent
vivre en sécurité la côte à côte la
palestine et israël avec comme capitale
partagée parce que c'est leur histoire
leur histoire religieuse aussi qui est
celle de jérusalem
benyamin nétanyahou doit être à paris ce
dimanche ça va être compliqué pour
emmanuel macron pauvre je pense pas
parce qu'il va lui il va lui redis
valurent dire ça ce qui est compliqué et
quasi absolue c'est de régler le sort
juridique de gm on sait depuis 67 cette
position-là qui dirait capitale partagée
de deux états passons la partage
géographiquement mais maintenant qu'il
ya des italiens des deux côtés des juges
de côté c'est quasiment impossible
physiquement d'arrivée les séparer et
soit on fait une capitale enfin une
ville ouverte où il la capitale des deux
états dans la même ville avec des
autorités civiles policières des deux
états qui seraient au touche à touche et
ça paraît extrêmement compliqué c'est à
dire que la question de comment résoudre
le statut de jérusalem
c'est monstrueusement compliqué je
rentre implicitement la décision de
jones 0,8 donne un sens au delà de ce
qu'on a dû au delà du conjoncturel c'est
une renonciation aux deux états c'est
l'idée que la paix parmi les tags
il ne va pas jusqu'à le dire non mais
c'est une étape de plus dans la dans le
district otages systématique des accords
d'oslo et des perspectives de paix sur
la base de deux états ce qui d'ailleurs
va dans le sens de ce que disait tout à
l'heure sur le l'embarras possible une
partie des autorités
israélienne c'est la caution qui sont
prises tout de suite de dire que cela ne
change rien et on se demande d'ailleurs
pourquoi serez chargé quelque chose aux
règles en vigueur sur l' usage des lieux
saints du mont du temple avec la
fréquentation très réglementé des
israéliens des juifs des gars du mont du
temple pour visiter et non pas pour
prier on avait dans le figaro ce matin
un article intéressant de normanville
sur le jeu justement double jeu
diplomatique avec les équipes de
l'administration américaine sont
amplement doublé par le gendre jared
kushner et le côté justement un peu
erratique de cette diplomatie dont on ne
prend pas tout mais déjà tout à fait là
envoyait si j'ai bien compris pour
tenter c'est effectivement ce grand
accord avec l'arabie saoudite et israël
et peut-être même la turquie est
derrière contre les contre les chiites
si on comprend bien c'est trump lui-même
qui est en train de le fiche en l'air
sans d'accord que son propre gendre
étaient censés négocier
voilà les images qu'on voyait là à
l'écran le risque qui est derrière est
le récit de donner des arguments aux
plus radicaux parmi les palestiniens qui
maintenant vont dire voilà c'est sûr
moqué de nous a une fois de plus on y va
et demain c'est la prière du vendredi
pour les musulmans et l'esplanade des
mosquées qui risque effectivement de
s'embraser comme c'est déjà le cas
d'ailleurs avec des échauffourées dès
aujourd'hui dans les territoires avec
ramallah à bethléem alors les l'ale dont
vous êtes toujours toujours 53 % estimé
que vous ne venez pas à coup de poker de
donald p on va passer au sujet de
l'insécurité en france cette fois ci une
insécurité
alors c'est un chiffre qui fait réagir
10 millions de français c'est à dire
plus d'un sur cinq déclarent vivre en
insécurité
c'est le résultat d'une enquête de
l'observatoire de la délinquance
laquelle le figaro a consacré deux pages
ce matin c'est le plus haut niveau de
sentiment d'insécurité observé depuis
dix ans avec une autre première si on
peut dire le terrorisme arrivent en tête
des préoccupations majeures des français
bien avant le chômage
vous pouvez comptez vous continuer à
vous prononcer sur cette question via
twitter emmanuel rivière elle dit quoi
cette étude elle est confirmée par vos
enquêtes ce côté
sentiment d'insécurité qui ne cesse
d'augmenter 13 dans la nature même
méthodologique des enquêtes de
victimation que c'est plutôt elle qui
est le juge de touche des autres
enquêtes
effectivement la proportion de français
qui disent vivre la sécurité corrobore
notamment la proportion de gens qui
disent qu'ils partagent le sentiment
dans les enquêtes eurobaromètre autour
de 20 % pour la france un peu pour un
petit peu en dessous de la moyenne de la
moyenne européenne c'est pas très
éloigné donc c'est un premier d'aiguiser
qu'ont fait les allemands répondent à
peu près dans la même proportion est de
victimation je pense que ça va moi je
dis qu'on verse pas aujourd'hui je sais
pas ce que ça veut dire pour le risque
d'être d'être un peu jargonneux parfois
les enquêtes de victimation consiste en
fait à demander à une population la
population générale
un échantillon représentatif sur des
dimensions extrêmement factuel
de quels actes donc dans leur définition
juridique
ils ont été témoins ou victimes ce qui
les distingue des enquêtes c'est vrai
que c'est un peu tout ce chiffre là
comment que j'étais en train d'évoquer
où on ne traduit un sentiment est ce que
vous avez le sentiment de vivre en
sécurité
visiblement les enquêtes de victimation
ici comprend les deux mais la vraie
vocation l enquête de victimation c'est
de comptabiliser autrement que par le
dépôt de plainte qui est une donnée
instable la vie tu sais que nombre de
victimes dans l'impression de ça c'était
une revendication depuis des années tous
les spécialistes de criminologie qui
disent que les enquêtes les statistiques
policières c'est pas qu'elle soit fausse
mais on ne sait jamais quand elle monte
ou quand elles baissent si c'est parce
qu'il ya plus ou moins de crimes ou
parce que la police est plus ou moins
active est d'accord il suffit qu'une
police soit plus efficace et le taux
d'affaires augmente donc ils disent ça
suffit pas il faut un deuxième
indicateur par police et d'autre part
des bons plats des potagers longue
sentiment tout d'un coup nous mettons
cartes bancaires que ça sert plus qu'à
l'époque où vous volez sert à rien
déposé plainte
oui oui quand on est pourtant c'est en
tout cas moins de vélos rollers et c'est
pendant très longtemps pour le viol par
exemple que les sommes allés par le
criminologue sadis bon netbook passé
mais il faut des enquêtes de victimation
qui sont un autre moyen de dames étaient
deux
logis sur le sentiment d'insécurité ski
53 % de nos internautes estiment que
c'est une réalité avec un sentiment mais
qu'est ce que c'est pour les gens la
différence entre un sentiment une
réalité si les réponses se faisait en
stricte nationalité il faudrait avoir
beaucoup plus peur de l'insécurité
routière que du terrorisme
le risque de se faire tuer quand on est
piéton à paris par exemple est beaucoup
plus grand que le risque d'être victime
d'un attentat terroriste
donc ça ne sommes pas des réponses
rationnelles pourquoi parce que les
sentiments ne sont pas rationnels parce
que depuis la mort la nuit des temps
enfin en tout cas depuis des décennies
on s'est habitué à l'insécurité routière
et puis elle est globalement au fil des
ans tout casser en temps long elle est à
la baisse et le terrorisme quelque chose
d'absolument nouveau et qui peut frapper
n'importe qui n'importe quand donc là le
type date provoque un sentiment une
subjectivité infiniment supérieur à
l'objectivité et à la raison et donc le
décalage et quelque sorte une fois qu'on
a dit ça devient normal et même une
augmentation d'une insécurité d'une
violence au quotidien que les gens
ressentent
parce qu'ils sont fait piquer leur
sac-à-main piquer leur portable tous des
enfants qui sont volés avec six
médiateurs dans leur tour puis y est
c'est qu'il ya plutôt baisse non de la
réalité même si parfois ce que j'ai lu
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
inspection était la même chose à part on
parle pas des mêmes choses parce que les
crimes les crimes de sang sa baisse les
cambriolages cambriolages s'arrête parce
qu'on a renforcé les moyens de
protection des voitures on peut plus
voler une voiture ça devient très
difficile des blindages des portes
en revanche les agressions dans le métro
dans la rue les gens qui font qu'à ses
dauphines notamment les salles ratissant
les femmes y en a de plus que je campais
parce que parce qu'ils m'ont parce que
dans les choses parce que je voyais
cambriolages qui baisse c'est juste à
côté il y avait forte montée des
problèmes de fraude bancaire de fraude à
la carte bleue ça faudra quatre blessés
très emmerdant mais c'est pas du tout le
même préjudice qu à un cambriolage
un cambriolage on a l'impression d'avoir
été violée de cétacés affreux et alors
que le truc à la carte bancaire ont
cessé on n'a personne n'a envie de se
faire tirer 100 euros sa carte bancaire
mais en général les banques remboursent
donc
il ya un décalage entre la réalité et
les sentiments et ça a été très très
visible ou tout blanc dès 2000 au moment
de la compétition qui verra jusqu'à
éliminer du premier à l'issue du premier
tour et un très fort sentiment
d'insécurité dans le pays avec
l'insécurité première préoccupation des
français
et cette réponse là va se dégonfler en
quelques mois nicolas sarkozy devenu
président ministre de l'intérieur dans
des proportions qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la réalité dure puisque la
délinquance
maintenant les perceptions sont aussi
des faits sociaux du temps dans mon
métier
quand vous avez dans l' enquête qui a
rendu public par le figaro quarante pour
cent des gens qui se disent dans la
sécurité qui disent par ailleurs ben je
fais des détours gentil apporte au
quotidien et si on y réfléchit bien
l'insécurité dans toutes ses dimensions
et une présence incroyable dans notre
vie quotidienne avec des forts
contrastes pour finir avant de te
laisser la parole entre les zones
urbaines et puis d'autres zones qui
s'est traduit une grosse attente pour la
police de sécurité au quotidien tels sur
wii un drame mais ce que dans ce que
disent et bien évidemment la question
d'un secret dans toutes ses dimensions
je pense que c'est ça aussi qui explique
que temps en temps ce n'est de l'est le
sentiment puisse monter dedans c'est que
l'insécurité c'est un phénomène global
qui est un effet qui va bien au delà de
la question de la délinquance c'est
l'insécurité économique l'emploi le
chômage la sécurité identitaire
l'immigration tout ça fait système est
un on se sent en insécurité parce que on
sent que le monde bouge et qu'on sait
pas monde donc ça n'est les gens ne sont
pas statisticiens lié à un centriste
insécurité il va se il peut prendre
mille chemins différents
moi j'avais vu une enquête je suis
demandé à l'ado clés de ses cuvées alors
je vois l'oeil est dans le jdd en
septembre dernier le jdd ile-de-france y
avait une grande une grande enquête
institut kandar de ses meetings
voilà et l'insu cantat est le titre du
jdd c'était la peur baisse en ile de
france donc c'est exactement le
contraire parce qu'on tue aujourd'hui
alors eh bien c'était dessus juste sur
l'île de france mais ça veut dire quoi
en ile-de-france et des gens qui sont
heureux et le reste la france a peur est
la peur baisse dans la région qu il se
trouve que la langue est qu elle fait
référence une enquête pour eelv enfin
pas pour la région mais pour une
institution qui s'occupe des intérêts
c'est que quelle île de france
en attendant les servir c'est donc en
ile de france les gens ont moins peur
donc là c'est qu'ils ont moins de 5
sentiment d'insécurité ça que vous
disent que disait cette enquête en
septembre en tout cas effectivement par
rapport à l'enquêté précédente l accord
plusieurs années aussi alors que les
enquêtes de victimation me semble-t-il
est sur une autre une autre fréquence
mais enfin il ya de toute façon une
prégnance assez forte de la question de
la sécurité est ce qui est intéressant
c'est que dans le temps aussi
finalement ce qu'on va mettre derrière
varie de manière considérable
aujourd'hui sera que le terrorisme
occupe une place démesurée par rapport
au risque il ya 15 ans c'était les
violences urbaines qui était extrêmement
présent dans le discours des gens sur
l'insécurité
maintenant c'est effectivement la peur
du chapardage un peu violent de la et
mais voilà il ya des événements qui vont
prendre une dimension très au delà de
leurs fréquences dans la population
on va parler un petit peu de l'élection
à la présidence des républicains c'est
ce dimanche
demain nicolas sarkoz riz donnera un
coup de pouce à laurent wauquiez déjà
grand favori de l'élection
les deux hommes se rencontrent en effet
à lyon ce scrutin au taux de
participation très incertain ne suscite
pas beaucoup d'intérêt il en plus
écrasés médiatiquement par la
disparition de johnny hallyday le camp
wauquiez espère que son champion
l'emportera dès le premier tour
on regarde le porte parole de laurent
wauquiez gilles platret il était hier
l'invité du talk du figaro il était
interrogé par extraire
nous tablons sur une participation
minimale de 50 milles ça nous paraît
raisonnable dans l'état actuel de la
situation politique on va encore nicolas
sarkozy avait repris deux parties
s'étaient 156000 voyez plus d'adhérents
oui aujourd'hui ça voudrait dire si on
fait la proportion que il faudrait 126
villes je crois votants par rapport au
nombre d'adhérents on n'y arrivera pas
je pense qu'on n'y arrivera pas sera pas
au futur et je peux vous donner une
autre statistique parce que si on fait
des comparaisons je regarde avec un peu
plus longs en 2002 alain juppé avait été
élu à la tête de l'ump qui venait de se
créer avec 37 mille voix mais sur les 45
si oui mais on est quand même pas dans
une proportion aussi forte
donc on attend le résultat la
participation c'est une chose déjà
alexis pour le coup de pouce de sarkozy
a évoqué c'est un est visée
ça vient tard ça vient après le premier
ne sais pas le premier signal qu'il
envoie je pense que ça veut évoquer
s'est dit que c'était pas plus mal pour
booster ce les intentions de vote il
reste 1 chez les militants notamment un
électorat qui reste très sarkozyste donc
le fait de bénéficier de cette espèce de
bénédiction juste avant le vote ne peut
pas ça peut faire de mal après moi c'est
quand le chiffre parce que tout le monde
strictement aucune importance
y a qu'à regarder déjà le score fleuve
qualité françois fillon à la primaire la
fin des primes à la droite record le
fond françois fillon bon on a vu ce que
ça donnait la bataille devant france 2
wauquiez lgv est et sera bien difficile
une fois qu'il aura gagné le fait qu'il
a été élu par 30 via ses contacts dans
huit jours plus personne n'ose en est
d'accord
malheureusement oui d'accord pense pas
que je pense pas que le chiffre soit
très important peut-être qu'il ya une
certaine ce qui serait ennuyeux pour lui
se traite pas être élu au premier tour
compte tenu de tout ce qu'on attend
enfin je pense qu'il sera élu au premier
tour mais s'il n'était pas ça serait
quand même un signe un petit peu de
difficulté et après après tout comment
cependant quelque sorte
moi je suis de ceux qui croient que même
avec une participation faible
le fait de devenir président du parti
des républicains
même dans un parti dans un assez triste
état va lui donner une légitimité
nouvelle une popularité qui va augmenter
un rôle reconnu deux chefs de
l'opposition et qu'en plus la
multiplication des égarements pour ces
voiliers internes le chef de
l'opposition parce qu'il ya mélenchon
donc peut-être qu'il prétend solar
c'était justement la voix d'or les
interruptions oui je pense que les
égarements de mélenchon je cherchais un
terme très susceptibles provoqué un
déchaînement de la part des réseaux
sociaux font qu' il ya un besoin d'une
place il ya un besoin d'opposition il ya
un besoin de quelqu'un pour l'incarner
qu assez vite
marine le pen en difficulté mélenchon
erratique
il peut occuper cette place un
adversaire redoutable manyamagan bon
alors moi là pour le coup je parle de
gauche donc vu l'état dans lequel la
gauche aujourd'hui je n'irai certes moi
ça serait l'hôpital et la charité je
voulais je vais aller me moquer de d d d
d d d d problème de la droite en ce
moment c'est justement la question au
sérieux parce que effectivement la
président de la république l'entourage
de les manier macross redoute quand même
le renvoi qu'il le prenne pas pour
n'importe quel pari alors une chose et
quand il sera élu mais en tout cas
puisque la question était sur l'élection
elle même
il ya une vraie lassitude par rapport
aux élections c'est tout à l'heure vous
disiez le legends sera lé parce que
c'est dépassé par johnny etc
enfin de toute façon vous parliez de la
lède de la primaire fillon etc c'était
un événement national
là on en a marre on aura du mal à s'y
faire leur après effectivement vous
qu'on verra comme on va se débrouiller
laurent wauquiez je pense que il ya
quand même il ya quand même un risque
qui est clair mais là je répète ce que
tous les jeux nes politique disant leurs
papiers tout le temps à raison il ya un
risque est clair qui est qui va
tellement du côté du front national qui
va perdre tout le côté droite modérée la
droite européenne à droite républicaine
et c'est donc voilà c'est ça qui va
jouer donc pour l'instant son problème à
lui c'est plutôt dans son camp que par
rapport en opposition au gouvernement me
semble-t-il la nécessité de
rassemblement on en parle aussi déjà
beaucoup pour l'après maël de calan
il va peser combien est-ce que ça va
être un dimension laurent wauquiez va
devoir tenir compte ça va dépendre du
score sera de me répéter mais le
rassemblement des personnes il se fera
pas ce qu'il se fait toujours si ça
marche deux côtés de wauquiez mails de
calan viendra puis valérie pécresse si
ça marche finira par venir même vous
avez bertrand un beau jour se dira s'il
n'a pas entre temps été nommé premier
ministre par macron or après tout
pourquoi pas donc la grille de calandre
alors c'est moi je pense que là encore
c'est vraiment pas le sujet il faut
éviter d'injurier les gens de les avoir
tous contre soi mais c'est pas la
bataille la bataille très difficile pour
vos pieds c'est de réconcilier ce sont
ces électorats de ces crimes en panne il
ne fait rare il est patron demande et
qui le soir après ça on verra c'est de
ne pas faire fuir que vous tout
l'électorat bourgeois modéré prenne pas
ses jambes à son cou re pour l'instant
il est quand même très chez makro mais
c'est aussi et je dirais d'abord de
faire revenir lectorat populaire droite
etc qui est partie sous marine le pen
donc et puis ensuite de trouver le
ciment qui va faire tenir tout ça
ensemble banques c'est extrêmement
difficile mais je pense que le problème
même si mal de cadres un plein de
qualités c'est pas mal de calan ou
pierre ou paul ou jacques où nous le
rend fort probablement la menace en tout
cas on me signale que on revient au
sujet d'israël une alerte rouge a été
lancée parce que deux roquettes ont été
tirées depuis gaza
par ailleurs la question effectivement
cette élection des républicains est elle
un flop annoncé ban aux internautes
répondent oui à 79% alors effectivement
on a demain dans le figaro un sondage
alexis un sondage au doxa d'être sous
kde shooting sur laquelle l'élection des
républicains laurent wauquiez a une
image quand même très dégradée si on
offre allemands donnaient des résultats
parce que c'est juste les commentaires
le résultat est dit pour lui une
majorité l'image des du probable futur
patron des républicains
alors c'est pas j'ai pas le chiffre
exact mais elle elle est qualifiée de
très dégradé oui on dit en gros il va
gagner mais même âge hybride dans
l'électorat en général il est trés il
est trés rejeter pas étonnant mais y
compris dans l'électorat de droite
oui mais j'ai pas eu les chiffres c'est
pas bon non voilà c'est certain
ça fait semblant d'être proposée pour
ceux qui n'ont pas jeté le figaro
magazine la semaine dernière une
excellente enquête a testé
qu'effectivement le pays n'attend pas
d'un commerçant qui n'attend pas avec
une impatience un contenu laurent
wauquiez est que chez les républicains
ceux qui souhaitent le voir jouer un
rôle et je parle des sympathisants
républicains ne sont que la moitié donc
il ya vraiment un travail important à
faire après là sont ceux qui vont voter
sont les adhérents
la raison pour laquelle ça va faire un
flop même si c'est une population qu'on
connaît mal c'est pas imputable à
laurent wauquiez c'est qu'il ya zéro
suspense apparemment à tort ou à raison
on ne considère pas que florence
portillon malbec un large choix de
véritables concurrents ce qui pose la
question d'ailleurs pourquoi est-ce que
le rassemblement n'a pas été entamée
avant parce que qui vont dans une
compétition incertaine il aurait été
stratégiquement essentiel de rassembler
autour du coeur de ce qu'on sait être
l'identité de valeur l'opération les
républicains ils sont très très
sarkozyste s'il avait donné une place à
mal de calan forexpros télé on ne dira
le raid il achète pour pâques et
d'abdominaux non je parle pas d'eux des
places qui leur donne mais simplement de
laisser ce soin baup enfermé d'ailleurs
ça se voit dans nos enquêtes dans une
posture très droitière dont il a besoin
pour gagner
non il va pour gagner c'est pour la
presse m mais si t'es pas du tout pour
gagner pour gagner ce match mais diana
la chose d'assez étonnant si on prends 5
secondes de la droite modérée qui
surligne assez calme et du pays six
états
si vous prenez wauquiez qui surligne en
effet très droitière mais après si vous
regardez les électeurs sur les sujets
sur lesquels il est très droitier il est
en harmonie avec les électeurs
républicains et donc comment se fait-il
qu à ce point en harmonie avec les
républicains lui ne soit pas plus
populaire et est ce que l'élection va
changer ça c'est ça tu les quais de
seine est il un problème personnel de
laurent wauquiez et il va falloir casser
quelque chose pour que l'île ait
adéquation entre la popularité et le
fait qu'il ait sur les idées de la
droite
eh bien on verra tout cela ce week end
l'élection
bravo l'élection dimanche elle
des républicains samedi cet hommage
populaire à johnny hallyday et demain
aux invalides pour jean d'ormesson
merci à beaucoup nous avoir suivis et
vous nous retrouver demain pour un
nouveau point de vue présentée par
guillaume roquette